[Musique]
ils étaient seize candidats à la
présidence du conseil départemental des
jeunes après leur représentation
respective
les collégiens présents dans l'hémicycle
ont voté pour l'élection de la nouvelle
mandature
il aura fallu un second tour et c'est
mélissa boos quand élève de 3e au
collège de trois mares qui est élue
présidente du conseil départemental des
jeunes pour son monde à 2019 2020
mes projets et nos projets du coup entre
tous les conseillers départementaux
jeunes
j'ai proposé ils ont voté pour une
action contre la pollution pour la
solidarité entre tous les jeunes de
l'île et tout le reste c'est juste je
reste à leur écoute en fait celle amiens
de demain donc il nous faut nous appuyer
sur route pour apporter en tous les cas
les projets du conseil départemental
le nouveau bureau du cdj intègre de
nouveaux vice présidents alan mangata du
collège henri matisse et loïc le bond du
collège la marine la présidente sortante
elodie boyer retrace son année de
mandature avec des actions de
sensibilisation sur les droits de
l'enfant la sécurité routière et les 30
ans du cdj je parlerai toujours des 30
ans du cdj parce que c'est vrai que ça a
été l'élément moteur de ma mandature
donc avec la venue des délégations
métropolitaine est une attraction qui
m'a beaucoup tenu à coeur c'est l'action
à l'ehpad pour la fête des mères si je
me trompe pas des mères vous défaire le
conseil départemental des jeunes de la
réunion est composée de collégiens de la
5e à la 3e des 85 collèges de l'île
cette instance contribuer à faire
émerger les idées et les opinions de ces
jeunes citoyens engagés
[Musique]